what up space fam golson here from anime
up we're back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
one piece story today we got massive
straw hat power upgrades that continue
to shock and propel the straw hats to
yonko level crew and eventually beyond
so make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy seeing these one-piece
reviews and want to keep them coming the
best thing you could do is channel the
pirate king within and smash that like
button like it was a giant azure dragon
remember that smashing that like button
is pyroking energy and passing is orochi
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future one piece videos and
while you wait for the next chapter to
drop feel free to check out my growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on all the yonko warlords supernovas
admirals and much more link to that is
in the description now without further
ado let's jump into it spoilers and all
this week we got luffy on the cover of
shonen jump letting us know there will
be a trivia event commemorating the
quote-unquote climax of the beast's
pirates conflict a hype sentence in and
of itself and we also get a cover spread
of the straw hats dressed as video game
characters like zorro dressed as link
and frankie seemingly as donkey kong
loved this and robin and nami are
looking fine as usual as robin is in her
demon form and nami is the gamer girl
playing against usopp but let's get to
the chapter itself as cp zero are
discussing the fact that there is
another dragon besides kaido and that it
even matches the devil fruit megapunk
made and this ability to effectively
clone any devil fruit perhaps as many
times as you want is just insane to
think about when we started looking at
op fruits like kaidos or the tremor
trevor fruit or the dark dark fruit
although this is crazy info cp 0 seems
calm about it thinking it will just help
the two sides take each other out the
bombshells finally dropped that in the
unlikely case that kaido is defeated
it's been decided that the world
government will annex the independent
land of wano this is how war often works
and what blackbeard did so well in the
paramount war if you have two enemies as
every risk player knows let them fight
it out while you build up resources in
australia then when the forces are weak
you swoop in and take the easy w with
minimal losses i'm not at all surprised
that the world government would plan
this but i do wonder who else may be
preparing a similar plan like blackbeard
for instance and why are they adamant
about only attacking if luffy wins
especially if kaido side is heavily
weakened but i suppose they have too
much respect for the yonko's strength to
risk that and in their defense they
probably thought the straw hats wouldn't
even tire out kaido's forces that much
still on the other side of the line the
question comes how likely is it that the
ships already on their way to wanna will
be needed and he's told that despite the
switch from 30 000 kaido men vs 5400
samurai men pre-fights to 12 000 kaido
men in the present versus 8 000 samurai
our cp 0 go player still can't even
picture kaido losing despite the fact
that it seems like momentum is
definitely on our side it's still not
even thinkable that kaido could lose
that definitely begs the question if
they're so sure why waste force is
waiting around and doing nothing but i
guess the opportunity aka the
risk-reward ratio is just too good to
pass up if by some miracle kaido loses
they'd get to take the strongest
creature in the world's territory which
would be such a huge demonstration of
power for the world government it would
boost their reputation to no end and
they could finally squash the luffy who
embarrassed them big time by doing stuff
like causing a massive prison break we
see that rob lucci is the one on the
other end and he agrees that he can't
picture kaido losing but he says there's
another order concerning the straw hats
the capture of nico robin so even if
kaido wins that's something they do want
enough to prioritize over almost
everything else right now it's not the
first time rob's chased robin but it
definitely adds even more drama to this
literal powder keg of a conflict right
now obviously this leads to the
possibility of brook getting into a big
fight in order to keep robin safe which
he hasn't had yet in this arc unlike
robin herself whose victory over black
maria was just insanely good i gotta
give props to oda for just how packed
and insane this war is right now we have
luffy fighting the strongest creature in
the world big mom fighting kid in law
zoro and sanji fighting kaido's
strongest commanders the island about to
fall and explode if kylo gets too tired
if he doesn't get too tired it's about
to land on the capital there's a
successful clone of kaido's mythical
zone fruit in momo who's aged 20 years
there's another new mythical zone in
yamato now the marines are preparing
their attack while they also target nico
robin again and that's only some of the
stuff we know so far shanks and
blackbeard are just two other of the
many hyped characters that may well show
up here as well my god what a climax
this will be it really seems all but
hopeless right now for the straw hats
because if luffy somehow beats kaido
which many people can't even imagine
then a the island might explode and b if
it doesn't the marines are going to be
waiting for them we may really need
something like shanks showing up at the
paramount war to ensure the survival of
the tired straw hats after this conflict
let me know what you expect to happen
what will save the straw hats from the
marines after they barely overcome
kaido's forces we get a quick scene of
the pervy gentleman brooke taking great
pride in protecting nami and she praises
him for it i absolutely love this
dynamic just gotta say that we then turn
to momo freaking out as usual because
they are only five minutes away and the
clouds aren't coming out as intended the
classic anime snot drips out of momo's
dragon nose as he faces the fact that
countless people will die if he can't
pull this off in the meantime yamato is
trying to make sure the oversized bomb
doesn't go off in her own way she told
momo she may be able to minimize the
potential damage and if she doesn't do
something the number of casualties will
be way worse should the worst happen
since she did this it's not as easy to
believe that momo will straightforwardly
solve the problem as first expected or
else why would oda have yamato
pointlessly go there there will be a
point here if it's only for her to
encounter another character or for her
to have access to the explosive to use
in another way later we shall see
perhaps momo will succeed in cushioning
the blow with his clouds and guiding the
castle away from the capital but the
bombs will still have to be dealt with
or else the explosion still would have
been big enough to wipe out the city
that way everyone contributes something
to the ultimate saving of the capital
and it would make a lot of sense since
this mythical wolf zone is the guardian
deity of wano we also see yamato's full
wolf form which looks great and people
remark that it's huge as well we then
jump to one of the biggest fights sanji
vs queen queen is begging for sanji to
get serious and use the raid suit like
he did against king it's funny to see
how he's jealous that he's not getting
the same treatment king got even though
king seems ready to use any means
necessary to beat zoro totally
unconcerned if zoro is actually at his
best or not sanji tells queen that he
won't use the crappy suit he doesn't
want to be associated with that family
he lands a kick on queen that does
impress the commander but doesn't really
have any lasting effects or slow him
down sanji seems tired while queen
changes into his dino form ready for
more sanji thinks about what he can do
to queen's insanely tough dino hide
queen finally promises to show the
unaltered raw power of a dinosaur the
beast that ruled the world for over a
hundred million years everyone is
getting excited to see the true power of
an ancient beast and then he uses the
move brachiosaur hiss and to everyone's
shock as if they were seeing a
triceracopter queen's head and tail are
launched giving him the body of a snake
and as if all that talking about true
power and not using augmentations wasn't
funny enough as he wraps around sanji he
even says that this serpentine form is
the true nature of the brachiosaurus
obviously that's not the case dinosaurs
don't just rock it out of their bodies
whenever they feel like it to attack an
opponent but it very much adds to the
humor of the triceracopter we saw before
i'm just thinking that some little kids
might really start saying in a class
about dinosaurs that the true nature of
our triceratops is that of a helicopter
and a brachiosaurus is that of a giant
snake queen says no one's ever escaped
his brachial hold which adds to the
tension but i can't help but think we
hear stuff like that all the time with
strong attacks and shown in an anime
we're told no one survived after this
attack and so on and so forth only for
our protagonists to obviously survive
but this one is really giving sanji
trouble and queen even says that tons of
armament hockey masters have had their
bones crushed under this pressure their
innards damage beyond repair queen is
talking big saying that he expected more
from judges brat he then offers to let
him go if sanji shows him the
capabilities of germa and sanji refuses
despite the pain he's undergoing you
gotta love how both zorro and sanji are
bosses when it comes to handling pain
and refusing to give in just because of
pain queen goes on to explain that
things are even worse than they look and
they do look really bad for sanji right
now his body is not just shedded skin
because he's a scientist he's equipped
launchers so that they could blow sanji
up after his bones and innards are
destroyed but it launches prematurely
hidden queen he snaps saying that he was
just referencing it and he didn't say to
use it but when he says he didn't say to
use it he does say use it and it
launches again hidden queen so he can
really feel at this time and freeing
sanji who looks like a zombie because
he's been crushed so bad queen even
thinks he's as good as dead and he
probably would be under different
circumstances but shockingly sanji just
says it stings a bit but he can still
move all the bones in his body are
broken but then they all heal and sanji
realizes he's unlocked the same ability
as his siblings allowing him to take
much more damage and heal at an
extraordinary rate even more shocking
queen goes to slice him with a sword to
slice him and the sword breaks off of
sanji's face it's funny how instead of
being relieved sanji is mad saying he
doesn't want to become a monster too and
that's the perfect word choice as well
with this match up it still felt like
sanji was getting his monster trio
respect since jinbei handled otobiropo
instead of queen and now with this
powerup it looks like the matchup will
make sense and the monster trio of luffy
zorro and sanji may well continue to
remain supreme despite all the other
strong members that the crew has now
love to see sanji getting this treatment
and even queen is upset and sweating now
as the narrator tells us and i quote
awakening to new powers end quote this
is the perfect matchup too as queen will
probably have to face not only the
physical battle but accept that the
technology that allowed sanji to become
this monster may be superior than what
he can do which would be the ultimate
hit to his ego amazing stuff in an
amazing chapter overall as always let me
know your thoughts on it and what you
most look forward to happening next who
was your mvp here obviously i gotta go
with my boy sanji this power was heavily
foreshadowed but the extent of it is
crazy imagine breaking off by yonko
commander's sword with your face and
being annoyed by how strong you are what
a true monster he's become and i love it
i especially love that sanji can be this
strong without the suit and while
maintaining his own cool style that
we've gotten to know so well if you did
enjoy this video and want to keep them
coming channel the pirate king within
and smash that like button like it was a
giant snake shooting out of a dinosaur
body remember that smashing that like
button is pirate king energy and passing
is a rochi energy so choose wisely if
you have it make this the video you
subscribe and this is crucial hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one piece videos and while you wait for
the next chapter to drop feel free to
check out my growing one piece playlist
that includes videos on all the yonko
warlords supernova admirals and much
more link to that is in the description
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you